model number c pn h z 197 a wind turbine
transmission 15 tons of steel now lie in
the shop but something's wrong
technicians were unable to pinpoint the
problem on site let alone repair it the
wind and weather have taken their toll
things stopped running smoothly about
eight weeks ago
much like the drive belt in a car you
often don't see or hear anything until
it breaks down but if repairs aren't
made in time the whole transmission
might need replacing sensors within the
turbine housing had been transmitting
signals of abrasion it's time to act
but technicians need to take a closer
look to find out what's wrong
manufacturers say their transmissions
have a service life of seven to ten
years this one rang for nine
troubleshooting and repair are
complicated they can take days or even
weeks
hydraulic wrench has needed to remove
rusty nuts and bolts
let us meet and Klingon we can do it by
hand but it would take a ton of effort
first you heat it red hot or the torch
then put a four or five meter long pipe
on a wrench to get enough leverage to
loosen it both from a four foot boom an
hour later they still don't know if it's
worth making the repairs they have to
keep going
everything must be recorded so that the
customer can monitor the work later
that's why photo documentation is so
important the wind turbine operator pays
the bill no matter what they find
judging from the early deposits the
technician makes a prognosis yep come on
I think it's coming from the spur
opinion from the gearbox
Hiba cost you meanwhile the first
hundred photographs are being uploaded
so how much does a repair like this cost
as a reference point you can estimate
that on average work like this costs
about two-thirds of the price of the new
ones Neela and how much is that low
close depending on the transmission
class new would run between 100,000 and
200,000 euros put in perspective that
means the repair costs could range
between 70,000 and 140,000 euros the
planetary transmission is exposed
repairs looking like a reasonable
proposition but they'll only know for
sure once the clamping ring is down
about five thousand five hundred wind
turbines have been repaired in Germany
out of June 2013 by noontime they're
down to the Sun pinion the rows of teeth
are pitted so this part is ready for the
scrap heap replacement isn't a problem
this company makes their own
but the technicians find more damage
they can see that the anti friction
bearings are shot even before they open
them up
this is the heart of the transmission
and the part that's subject to the
greatest stress the bearings design
dates back at least a decade turbine
builders have learnt a lot since then
many of the 400 other parts are still as
good as new an engineer gives management
as status report they're the ones he'll
have to explain it all to the customer
later on the engineer says they won't be
able to put the ring gear back in while
at least the transmission housing was
intact
three weeks later about half of the
parts have been replaced overhauled or
recast when it's finally reassembled the
transmission is placed on a test stand
where it must run much more quietly than
before Germans are far more sensitive to
wind turbine noise than they used to be
but it's all paid off this CPN Hz 197
can go back in service fit once more for
Germany shift to renewable energy
you